welcome back a school in new york city
defending itself
after telling students not to say words
like mom
and dad apparently they think it could
be offensive
it's all part of a new inclusive
language directory that includes
suggestions
like this instead of mom and dad say
grown-ups
folks or family and merry christmas
becomes happy holidays or have a nice
break
the head of the school responding to
criticism he says quote so
if the boorish cancel culture press
wants to condemn us
a newly dubbed woke noho school of
politeness
dignity and respect then i embrace it
and i hope you will too jesse uh
what do you think of this uh are you
offended if i said to you hey jesse
happy holidays
me i'm so offended juan that's the war
on christmas
we've been over this we have
but i have a hunch that one of these
students is going to cancel me one day
i have a hunch that one of these social
justice warriors
is going to matriculate get a job at cnn
flag me for toxic masculinity
and i'm out of a job either that or
they're gonna join antifa
i mean these you're you're graduating
the next generation of
statue topplers of cartoon
cancelers this is bad stuff and it's not
just that i looked on their website
today juan
they have gay and lesbian club for fifth
graders
they do transgender study for sixth
graders
they have safe spaces in some of the
other language lingo curriculum
they say being colorblind is a bad thing
they said america is a white supremacist
society and
it's not good enough to just be not
racist you have to be an anti-racist
meaning you have to be ashamed of having
white skin
you have to renounce your white
privilege and then you have to take
ownership of all of the racial injustice
throughout the world that's a little
heavy for a
seventh grader who's trying to maybe
play baseball
and do homework don't you think juan
all right uh greg by the way today greg
the
nba suspended one of its players
uh and find him because he was playing a
video game and used an
anti-semitic slur now do you would you
consider that suspension and fine cancel
culture
i have no idea what you're talking about
was that in our uh
i wanted to talk about this this thing
that by the way uh jesse uh homework
homework some people don't have homes
how dare you
how dare you expect people to do
homework you know you're right the
bigger question here
is why is wokism everywhere and there's
like five
answers to that one it's decentralized
right there's no head to the snake
so it just pops up everywhere two it
terrifies corporations and people in
positions of power because they don't
know how to stop it
so they just roll over three there's a
low barrier to entry
you don't have to be smart to operate in
woke culture
you just have to parrot something you
already heard that's why so many stupid
people are drawn to it
three or four it's press friendly
meaning that
the media can fashion any kind of story
out of social justice
and a 24 year old untalented blogger
can wield power that he never had before
in his life a 24 year old mediocre
blogger can cancel out
a published author in his 70s just
because the guy's old and said something
stupid
and finally speaking of old there's no
there's a
missing older generation who would
rather ride off into the sunset
than to define our rights of speech
that's the sad part
you got to step up and share the risk
because it's all coming for you
all right martha mom and dad that one
struck that that one struck me
you know i guess the contrary thought is
family structures are changing in the
country
uh more people are in tune right now to
gender inclusion
what do you think about you know folks
parents
family as opposed to mom and dad i think
it's ridiculous
i mean i think that you know this is so
ridiculous and overboard
and obviously i want to be called a mom
by my kid's friends and i
i want my you know to be called the wife
of my husband
i like those labels i'm not
uncomfortable with other people's labels
and i'm fine with addressing them the
way that they want to be addressed
the thing is that these these ridiculous
institutions and these
layers of rules that they're coming out
with do you know how
poorly educated we are what a poorly
educated society we are creating and
people who don't understand the basics
of their history people who don't
understand the basics
of uh western civilization which i
understand now is even a term that is
not really
um considered to be appropriate you know
one of the things i saw today that i'm
reminded of when we talk about this is
sharon osborne
who was berated by the other people on
her show called the talk
because she stuck up for piers morgan
and so the argument goes like this if
piers morgan is racist
then and you're his friend and you stick
up for him then that makes you racist
she said no i am not
a racist person and they said look we
love you we know you don't think you're
a racist person
but unconsciously you are so it's you
you have to be
anti-racist outwardly anti-racist
otherwise
sharon poor sharon you are a racist is
what her friends were essentially
telling her on the set i mean if this is
what
we're doing i i i really fear for us as
a culture
we're supposed to be judging people on
the content of our character
not the color of our skin and and jesse
pointed out you know that being
colorblind is considered
an offense so that was the that's what i
grew up learning
um from martin luther king to judge
people by their character to try to not
see
some of these other divisions and i
think it's really sad the place that we
find ourselves in right now
katie uh final thoughts from you is this
a selective thing you know remember
we've seen uh trump try to cancel or
boycott goodyear
macy's hbo but now it looks like all of
it's coming from the right and saying oh
we don't like cancel culture
i have some great news for moms okay
this is great news for moms whose kids
are always momming them
mom mom they have an excuse to tell
their kids just to stop it's not allowed
it's offensive
go away and talk to your dad
and call them your folks
all right yes